the haunting of Hill House is a 2018
Netflix original horror show based on
the book of the same name
similar to the source material there's a
sinister side to the show and throughout
this video I'll be discussing the ending
of it as well as how I think the house
really won there will be heavy spoilers
and I definitely recommend that you
check out the show if you're a fan of
all things horror without the way I'm
definition and I ruin the show so you
don't have to hill house itself is pure
evil whilst we are never given a
concrete explanation to its powers the
house is able to bring forth
hallucinations act as a refuge for the
dead and Bend space of time the houses
main goal is to feed on the living so
that it can continue to thrive it does
this by driving people to the brink of
misery and insanity so that they take
their own lives throughout the show the
house is purposely creating custom
curated ghosts and specters that prey on
the crane family's worst fears each girl
and apparition has been purposely
designed with one goal in mind to bring
the family back to the Red Room which is
the houses stomach so that it can be
silly during the show of the house
twists and repurposes the Red Room so
that it appears to be a safe area in
which each member of the crane family
can relax to be digested to Luke it is a
treehouse
Steve Caesar Games rule Olivia a reading
room and so on it is a room which is
tailor-made towards them so that they
can feel some sense of sanity buzz also
being driven in
originally home to the hel family the
house managed to murder most of them
even going so far as to cause William
Hill to brick himself behind a wall our
fear which brings me to my next point
the houses greatest trick is that it
makes people wall themselves off from
the world and tricks them into believing
that they are safe within it so they
refuse to leave it does this
successfully to Olivia crane and almost
fools her into murdering their two
youngest children she does however
managed to get the Dudley's daughter
Abigail which plays into the next part
in the final episode we learn that the
father Hugh almost burnt the house down
but was stayed from doing so by the
Dudley's after Olivia murdered their
daughter Abigail they realized that the
house had kept us very alive and if it
were to be destroyed their daughter
would go with it so they make a deal
with the devil and convince you to
abstain from setting it alight to me
this is another trick that the house
pulls just as it is about to be
destroyed it manages to manipulate the
Dudley's into pulling at the
heartstrings of Hugh and puts him into a
position where he would have to be a
monster to deny them it's a smart move
that I haven't seen many people pick up
on and it allows the house to continue
to trick the cranes into coming back so
can feast on them once more they're
saying that the house always wins is
definitely true here even in the end it
manages to trick you into taking his own
life by making it appear that he has no
other option it truly highlights just
how sinister it is and it's a very smart
move that even tricks the audience into
thinking that there is somewhat of a
happy ending
to me this is hammered home by the fact
that the house has a clear control over
time we discovered that the bent neck
lady that horn Snell is actually a
version of her from the future that
committed suicide in a last-ditch
attempt at the moment of her death
Nell tries to travel back in time to
warn herself but ultimately this ends up
making her return to the house to commit
the act now obviously did not possess
the power herself so this was the house
playing its hand to cause her to return
there so it could feed once more
it's a brilliant reveal and definitely
stands as one of the strongest moments
in the show so what did you think of the
haunting of Hill House personally I
absolutely loved it it's everything I
wish American Horror Story would be and
it was incredibly well paced and acted
it has one of the best continuous shots
that I've ever seen in anything ever and
blew me away from start to finish do you
agree with my thought on how the house
always wins is there anything I missed
do you think that I should have just
called the Ghostbusters just comment
below and let me know this is a channel
for people who are heavy into horror so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe make sure you check out my
recent breakdown of the ending of the
new Netflix horror apostle linked at the
end of this one and if you want to
support the channel so I can bring more
videos like this check out my patreon
which is linked in the description
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]